you know I was gonna start this whole
intro thing by saying I can fix it but I
don't think we can fix this so new
trailer wreck-it Ralph - Ralph breaks
the internet wasn't planning to talk
about this even when I saw that he'd
come out because I thought I'm sure I
won't think any worse on it than I
thought
on the first trailer which I didn't
really like if you saw that then I
watched it and it hurt it
I felt physical pain watching this I'm
being metaphorical I didn't literally
but I did feel my yeah like the heat in
my face in my right flames on the side
of my face
so yeah fairly big fan of wreck-it Ralph
I've cosplayed as fixed as fix it Felix
yeah so before I even go down this
rabbit hole let me start by saying I may
be in a crazy majority on this because
I've said in the past and this is
generally true that between when I see a
new trailer piece of news about
development in a film series or show
that I like or what have you I generally
try to avoid finding out what other
people think about it before I record my
views because I want my views to be my
views I don't as much as I can help it I
don't want them overly tainted by having
read other think pieces or you know
other people's hot takes or whatever
in this case I I didn't dive too deep
but I did like just sort of browse a
couple of things just to see if I'd get
a general tendency and other people seem
to really really like all the stuff that
I
hated in this so maybe maybe and I'm
gonna put this up front maybe I am just
a grumpy bastard
like I'm distinctly open to that
possibility but holy God did I hate this
trailer oh it made me cringe so bad
okay let's start by backing up one of
the things that was wonderful about
wreck-it Ralph was that the references
to actual real world videogames were not
only few and far between
they were almost never lingered on like
really there's only two that come up and
there isn't even like that much emphasis
put on the put on the fact that the
references are there so basically
there's there's the villain meeting in
at the start where you know Ralph's
little support group and that's got a
mess of villain characters from other
videogames and we also see a fair number
of them in gran and great gaming station
Grand Central Station I can try for what
they call it now Game Central Station
there it is but again it's all
background they're all just kind of
they're the characters themselves are
not stopping to look at them and go whoa
ha and then doing these massive
interactions with them the only other
example is Qbert and you don't have to
know who Qbert is for his part to
function in the story and to still be
funny in the story for where it's
appropriate for him to be funny and and
and besides that like they were there
were not many because by and large the
first record Ralph had video game worlds
that were very much evocative of
specific errors and types of games but
they were original creations like hero's
duty was very much evocative of what was
at the time the sort of the current
trend of first-person shooters you had
sugar rush which was more evocative of
the 90s early 2000s just kart gaming
kind of craze record Ralph's was very
obviously a ripoff on on Donkey Kong
from a structural standpoint so you they
reaching for references but they were
still original creations that evoke to
these things so right off the bat it
kind of rubs me the wrong way when they
get in the internet and immediately we
are seeing Amazon and now let's have
basically a Google autofill joke and
look to be fair it's not the world's
worst joke but there are a few things
that will age any film faster than
trying to seem up-to-date and modern and
that's what this is feeling like with
these references and that that's why I'm
cringing throughout but even those
things cuz when like what I saw that
stuff in the trailer I didn't think I
was gonna do another video on it because
that I saw that sort of stuff in the
previous trailer and it annoyed me then
I didn't think this annoy me enough to
do another thing but then then we get
this and a lot of people ripped into the
emoji movie for its blatant product
placement for things like just dance and
candy crush and I can't even remember
what else I my kid watched the movie I
rented it and I have paid attention for
as long as I could stomach it but that
got a lot of heat and for some reason
when Disney does it but technically
these aren't product placements because
nobody paid to have their product there
because these are all things that happen
to be owned by the same company how
scary is that in the first place that
somehow the reaction that I primarily
saw it to this was WOW how awesome
that's cool and you know what I'm not
even necessarily I'm not I don't want it
to seem like I'm mad at fans for seeing
it this and liking it honestly i if you
like something I don't like any time
good awesome I'm happy for you I wish
I could have liked it I prefer to like
things as much as like [ __ ] I don't
actually enjoy not liking stuff but it
was just so weird to me that polarized
reaction because it I I don't really see
that big of a difference between what
the emoji movie got ripped to shreds for
doing and what this is doing and in my
mind it's made all the worse by having
one of your who appear to be two main
characters literally look over all the
other Disney products that your audience
could be shelling out money for and
going wow isn't this so awesome
Disney is really good at marketing they
have been for a long time and basically
anytime you see any Disney product
whether it is an actual Disney movie a
Pixar movie whether it is Marvel whether
it's Star Wars whether it's Muppets
anytime you see any of those movies
there are there is 50 million tons of
merchandise that exists that can benefit
off your enjoyment of that thing but by
and large those those films don't stop
themselves in the middle in order to
cross-promote
other things available under the same
corporate entity like this is insanity
what I just witnessed this was madness
and then there was the extended
preachers joke which like on a meta
textual level I want to like this joke
like I want to be like oh good on Disney
for like acknowledging some of the
weirdness and their things but it's so
weird and ham-fisted in this weird
lampshade hanging and again still
ultimately feels like more of a
marketing exercise because it feels like
just a way to shovel the princesses in
and then do now be able to market
penelope and the princess line is the
princess is all except that's what it
feels like even though on a meta textual
level I can look at what the scene is
doing
and you like get behind the theory of a
little bit of poking fun at the way
princess is having the pass been
utilizing Disney products but I stayed
because I saw this shot before that I
might like every cynicism part of my
brain was firing the hardest it is fired
in a while and I just how my fight this
is not a phrase I use I don't use this
phrase I make a point of not using it
because it annoys me but I can't think
of anything else I can't even I just
can't even I oh my god and if I'm gonna
stick another caveat at the end of this
and this is not me expressing hope
because now after two trailers I don't
have a lot or any honestly if if it
wasn't for the fact that my kid also
loves wreck-it Ralph and is gonna want
to see this I wouldn't be going to the
theater to see this now but what I'll
add on the end is that so far including
what we've seen they appear to be
isolated to a few set pieces it is
distinctly possible that the entire
extended Disney thing including the
princesses makes up no more than say
three minutes of the total run time of
the film and it's a one-off lark that is
distinctly possible that doesn't in my
mind really make it any less cynical but
it may be a brief divergence as opposed
to one of the major set pieces of the
entire film which in my mind would be
magnitudes worse and we still don't
really have a proper sense of the plot
of this thing and begin to be fair
looking back at the original trailers
for the original film we only had a very
vague sense of plot from those trailers
and actually I didn't rush out and see
the first record Ralph in the theater
because the trailers didn't really sell
me I don't think it had the best
trailers but I still think though
trailers were better than this so even
grading on the curve of oh the trailers
for the first film didn't seem all that
good I'd still can't stand this and then
of course we have the capper joke that
feels like they just were all over the
reddit page the the reddit movies
subreddit and just saw that and then
inserted that into the film and like I
[Music]
again it's not an awful joke but it
already feels outdated because it's a
joke I've been reading for months now
ever since the title was announced so it
still has that issue of trying to be
really of the moment and up-to-date and
already feeling old because that's what
tends to happen when you try and do that
and and also beyond the fact that it's
somehow maeín again in my mind makes it
worse have any character say breaks the
internet it's kind of a thing it's not
anymore
like it was what a year two years ago
how long ago did Kim Kardashian break
the internet and it was a thing for a
hot minute like it's not now I'm sure it
was when the script was being written
the first story was storyboards were
being done but it's that kind of
instantly how dated stuff along with the
cynicism of the of the intercompany
marketing that I just I loved the first
film it's one of my favorite Disney
films it is touching and is beautiful in
the end of it makes me cry in the best
way and out here I don't see that's
equal now so what are your thoughts how
about the newest trailer for wreck-it
Ralph - Ralph breaks the internet and
then makes a meme joke about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it there's
also something you can do such as like
and subscribe I've got a patreon you can
support me there and follow me on
Twitter and listen to a podcast buy
t-shirts blah blah blah blah blah blah
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]